do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back from a Game of Thrones Season eight
video well it's official my friends Game
of Thrones has finally come to an end I
do want to say it has been one hell of a
ride and I want to start off by thanking
all of you for supporting my channel I
hope that some of you were able to find
some enjoyment from this episode because
I know many of us have dedicated so much
of our time to this story as well as the
series I know there are still a lot of
things I wish they would have answered
before it ended but all I can do now is
hope that the books give us some of
those answers right now I want to give
some of my initial thoughts on the
episode then I will release another
video later this week like most of the
episodes this season there were many
things that I did like and there were
many things that I did not like we begin
right where the last episode ended the
attack on King's Landing was devastating
Daenerys Targaryen set fire to almost
everything in sight it's hard to imagine
how anyone could live in this city after
that battle the streets are covered by
the remains of mostly innocent civilians
and Lannister soldiers it basically
looks like the inside of an incinerator
there are some skeletons still intact
but what's left is mostly ash from the
thousands of fallen victims this is
obviously a very horrifying sight for
Jon Snow Davos and Tyrion Lannister
especially when you consider that this
was once the city that he called home
the crazy thing is Cersei always wanted
him dead dating all the way back to when
he was a child but I still felt bad for
him when he found his brother and
sisters dead bodies below the red key as
we all know he sacrificed his own life
in hopes of his brother surviving the
battle for King's Landing regardless of
what I thought about Cersei and Jaime's
final scene together it did suck to see
Tyrion find them like that one thing
that really did surprise me this episode
was how Jon Snow was acting near the
beginning one of the first things Jon
tries to do is stop grey worm from
executing the Lannister soldiers that
have surrendered it was obvious that Jon
did not want to see anyone
else have to die although they were
Lannister soldiers that did seem like
something John would do shortly after
this is when we see Daenerys Targaryen
come outside and address her entire army
she made it very clear that this will
not be the last battle now she wants to
go everywhere from Winterfell down to
Dorne from the Summer Isles to the Jade
Sea and everywhere in between
Dany made it known that she was only
getting started
he later says to Tyrion I cannot justify
what happened but then he goes on to
justify what happened he says something
along the lines of Dany is not her
father
Cersei made the choice to not open the
gates and surrender right away Dany saw
missandei get beheaded and her other
dragons shot out of the sky now maybe
I'm a dumbass but that sounds like John
was trying to justify what Danny did to
King's Landing John even said he didn't
know what he would have done if he were
the one on the back of the dragon I
could not believe that now I know he
loves Dany but holy [__] John you know
damn well you would not have done what
Danny did to all those innocent
civilians then we finally get a maester
aemon reference from the first season
[Music]
father was forced to choose between
honor on the one hand and those he loves
on the other what would you do do
whatever was right John finally starts
to come to the realization that maybe
Tyrion is right John knows what he
should do but he is blinded by his own
love for Daenerys even Tyrion says the
same thing about his brother Jaime knew
what he should have done but he was also
blinded by his own love for Cersei it
ended up costing him his own life and it
very well could have done the same thing
to Jon Snow how long would Daenerys have
allowed John to live knowing that he has
the rightful heir to the Iron Throne
as long as John is alive he would always
be a threat to what Danny has always
wanted for herself
it's not until Tyrion makes Jon realize
that it won't only be his life that's in
danger but it will also be his sister's
lives as well
we saw Ned Stark in a very similar
situation back in the first season Ned
Stark was ready to die but only when
Varys made him realize his daughter's
lives were in danger did Ned decide what
he should do to try to keep them safe
that's what ultimately led to Ned Stark
saying that Joffrey was the rightful
king of Westeros and I believe it's what
ultimately led to join Snow realizing
Danny had to die before she killed
anyone else this leads us right into the
next scene where we see Daenerys
Targaryen vision from the house of the
undying become a reality only this time
she actually does grab one of the swords
on the Iron Throne
she never does sit down because John
walks in shortly after once again I
thought this scene looked incredible
then Jon Snow walks in and Dany
continues to justify her actions as well
as stand by her decision to keep
fighting even though she now has the
Iron Throne it's very obvious that Jon
will have to kill Danny otherwise
everyone will be in danger
considering what Danny has done it did
not really bother me that she died now
that she had transformed into this new
character John had no other choice but
to stop Danny as soon as he could Danny
ends up getting killed right in front of
the Iron Throne like her father the Mad
King did when Jaime stabbed him in the
back
this almost immediately gets a response
out of drogon because him and Danny have
a connection to one another that runs
deeper than most of us could understand
even after death Danny and Joe go and
have a bond that could not be broken
instead of burning John alive gurgaon
instead turns his attention to the Iron
Throne arguably the main thing
responsible for driving Daenerys
Targaryen mad I'm not exactly sure how
dragon would know this but I did enjoy
getting to see the Iron Throne melted
down now I know John does have some
Targaryen blood but I was honestly
expecting drug on to burn John alive in
my opinion I think that's what drug on
would have actually done if they weren't
trying to keep join alive for another
reason and even if it wasn't drugged on
that killed John Snow I would like to
think that grey worm would have had him
executed immediately
they still had King's Landing under
their control and considering grey worm
was executing Lannister soldiers that
already surrendered I don't see why they
would have let Jon Snow live right after
he killed Danny
that did not make any sense to me so
then dragon grabs Danny's body and he
leaves the red key my guess is he has
taken her back east
now although Danny was born on
Dragonstone Westeros has never really
felt like her home
no one was accepting her and even as
Danny said no one
here was loving her either the last time
we saw drug on leave like this is when
Jorah and Tyrion saw him flying over
Valyria this is the ancestral home of
House Targaryen and I would like to
think this is where a drug on and Daini
are heading next
I know some fans were already asking if
drug on will fun conveyor to bring Danny
back to life but I honestly doubt it I
do think that Danny was always meant to
die in the end I think this will also
happen in the books but of course it
will not be as rushed as it was in the
show all right now this next scene
happened several weeks later all the
High Lords and ladies are now in King's
Landing
I have to be honest I did not like this
scene for several reasons so grey worm
and Tyrion come outside to meet everyone
and we finally see the man from Dorne
but we also see Ed Muir and Robin Arryn
again the last time we heard a ved
mirror was when Walder Frey said he had
him locked back up in the cells and
miios back in her cell God go killing my
son by little wouldn't be right did the
family a bad name we never saw anyone
let him out even after Arya went there
and killed almost everyone we never saw
her let ed mere out either he was locked
up down there for over half of the show
yet he somehow looks like nothing ever
happened I want to know why he wasn't
there during the Battle of Winterfell if
he was free and he had Riverrun there is
no reason why he should not have been
fighting during that battle he looks
healthy enough to fight to me Robin
Arryn wasn't there either but we all
know that he cannot fight but he did
send his army to help Winterfell fight
the dead anyways for some reason Tyrion
is the one calling all the shots at the
meeting even though he is standing there
in Chains by this time they have to know
that he let Jamie go free so he could
help Cersei get out of the city before
they died why would any of them want to
listen to anything he has to say
most of the lords and ladies that are
there already had more than enough
reasons to not like any of the
Lannisters I thought it was a little
ridiculous that he was standing here in
Chains telling everyone what they should
do anyway so they all decide that bran
the broken would be a good option for
King brand the broken is actually a
reference from the books this is
something that he thinks about to
himself he thinks is this what I am now
in the broken I don't want to be broken
I want to be a knight in that scene bran
even indicates that the whole reason why
he even came down to King's Landing was
because he knew this would happen so it
does look like bran has the ability to
see the future which is something I have
talked about in other videos at first he
was only getting glimpses of the future
but now that he has had time to analyze
all the visions he now knows what will
happen before it happens unfortunately
this is the last episode so we will
never see what this leads to next but I
do wonder if the children of the forests
are still behind the scenes trying to
orchestrate all of the events I made a
video about this over a year ago and I
will leave that link down below I would
recommend checking out that video
because I think most of what I said is
very relevant now that brain is the new
king of Westeros even in the books it
has said that green seers may be able to
see far into the future so you may be
wondering if brand-new that Danny would
kill everyone in King's Landing why
didn't he have someone stop her before
she did that well the only thing I can
really say is its most likely because if
he tried to change any of the events it
could have made things even worse than
they already were now assuming bran
wants what's good for the realm I'm sure
he had his reasons for letting things
happen the way that they were meant to
now if bran does not have good
intentions well I would only look to
what the children of the forest were
wanting ever since the first long night
started if you're interested in that
then like I said check out my other
video that's down below we then see our
first look at brain Starks new small
council in King's Landing Sam is the new
maester Brienne is the Lord Commander of
the Kingsguard and not only was Podrick
knighted but he's also on the Kingsguard
as well for some crazy reason brain is
allowing Bronn on the small Council
which doesn't make any sense to me he
did end up getting Highgarden so I was
definitely wrong about that prediction I
was right about Padraig getting knighted
in Brienne getting back on the
Kingsguard although I thought she would
do it for Sansa and not brand I'm
guessing that sir Davis is the master of
ships I'm not really sure if they
mentioned it or not but I guess that
makes sense most of this scene felt like
fanservice to me Sam then brings in a
book called A Song of Ice and Fire
bran starts to make jokes about brothels
Terry and even references that jackass
and the honey
and now brain finally decides to see
what one of the Dragons are up to they
know that the fans wanted to know how
Tyrians joke ended they know that the
fans wanted to see Sam writing down the
story of a game of Thrones so it felt
like they just added all this stuff to
one final scene to make some of us happy
it actually had the reverse effect on me
I did however love the scene where
Brienne was writing down Jamie's deeds
in the white book this is something I
have wanted to see happen for a very
long time
although Jamie did Brienne dirty in the
end she still did right by him that book
has haunted Jamie for years and Brienne
knew that because she was there one of
the times that Jamie said there is still
room left on his pages for good deeds
[Music]
thereafter known as the Kingslayer it's
the duty of the Lord Commander to fill
those pages there's still room left in
mine Jamie did not want to die as the
man only known for killing his king so I
did like that Brienne did that for Jamie
that was a nice way to end their stories
so then we find out that gray worm does
not kill Jon Snow but instead he is
allowing him to live out the rest of his
life at Castle black grey worm decides
to take the unsullied back to where him
and missandei we're talking about going
right before the Battle of Winterfell
unfortunately missandei later died but
grey worm still wants to go he might
even be taken Miss Anne days body back
there with him it's kind of hard to say
because they never mentioned it but
that's what I would like to think grey
worm seems to have been waiting to see
if Jon was actually leaving for Castle
black what I don't understand is why did
Jon still go even after grey worm and
the unsullied left King's Landing you
would think that as soon as they set
sail Bram would be like all right Jon
now that he's gone and we don't have to
worry about a battle breaking out you
don't actually have to go to Castle
black you can go ahead and do whatever
you want but then again we all know Jon
even if Bryan did say that Jon would
most likely still go live out the rest
of his life at Castle black the rest of
the Starks essentially got what they
wanted Arya decides to go west of
Westeros which is something she has
dreamed about for quite some time
as was his East the Las Rozas West but
what's west of Westeros I don't know
nobody does
it's where all the maps till the edge of
the world maybe I'd like to see that the
North becomes independent again and they
have sons as their queen they have laid
the tracks for songs of becoming the
queen ever since the first season of the
show
you'd have to leave me and so would you
you left your home to come here and I'd
be Queen someday and you will be queen
of all of them I'll be your queen just
like you I promise I won't hatch
anything even though it is kind of sad
to see Jon have to go back to Castle
black it does sort of make sense for his
character I really don't have any issues
with how their stories ended the only
one that really seemed out of nowhere
for me is how bran stark became the new
king it's not that I don't think it can
happen in the books or anything like
that it just doesn't feel right in this
show I do wish they had given themselves
some extra episodes to let all of that
unfold bran becoming the new King felt
like they just shoved it in at the very
end although I don't really like it I do
like that the Starks seem to be fairly
happy about how things ended Songza Arya
and Bryan all seemed to have gotten what
they wanted House Stark has always been
my favorite house so I really can't be
mad about that
Jon and ghost are reunited so that makes
me very happy and Jon even had a smile
on his face when he left Castle black
when Jon turned around right as the gate
was closing down it did feel like Jon
was closing that chapter of his life he
is leaving behind the Seven Kingdoms and
trade for his new life in the north
Jon never wanted the Iron Throne and he
never felt right at home in Winterfell
either although jon was sent to Castle
black it does seem like he will get the
live the rest of his life on his own
terms
something I mentioned in one of my last
videos was the conversation John and
maester aemon had back in the first
season
my father was Micah the first of his
name
my brother Aegon reigned after him when
I had refused and thrown and he was
followed by his son Aerys whom they
called the Mad King Haman Targaryen
Maester Aemon said how he gave up his
own claim to the Iron Throne by becoming
a maester and joining the Nights Watch
and in the end John essentially did the
same thing even the three-eyed Raven who
was also made up of ice and fire like
Jon Snow also joined the Nights Watch so
it's not a crazy thing to see a
Targaryen live out the rest of their
life at the wall or even beyond the wall
I think John was always suited to live
in the far north so I am fine with his
story ending right here like I said John
had a smile on his face at the end so if
he's happy that I'm happy anyways I
wanted to give some of my initial
thoughts on the episode let me know what
you thought about the ending leave your
comments down below I want to thank
everyone for watching the video and I
also want to thank everyone for
supporting the channel I hope you all
have a great day I will see you again
very soon bye
[Music]